y las largas filas vuelven a los
aeropuertos en eeuu millones de personas
han decidio viajar para la celebración
del día de acción de gracias a pesar de
los crecientes números de contagios por
kobe casi 9 muchos estadounidenses se
desplazan para reunirse en familia
voy a viajar para el día de acción de
gracias voy a ver a mi hija ancianos y
hasta ahora todo bien fue un poco
complicado encontrar estacionamiento
pero hasta ahora no parece estar
demasiado ocupado ya las esperas y las
multitudes recuerdan a la manera en que
transcurría la semana del festivo de
acción de gracias' antes de la pandemia
el viernes pasado las autoridades
estadounidenses reportaron el día más
concurrido en los aeropuertos desde que
se decretó la emergencia sanitaria con
2,24 millones de viajeros un récord que
también se vio en los ángeles
nuestro día más ocupado en lo que va del
año fue el viernes cuando 90.000
viajeros pasaron por el control de la
psa son cifras realmente alentadoras nos
dicen que la gente está lista y
dispuesta para regresar al aeropuerto y
viajar
al mismo tiempo se espera que 48 3
millones de personas viajen en su
vehículo hacia sus reuniones familiares
más de un millón que en el año pasado
aún con los precios de la gasolina más
altos desde 2014 los precios están altos
pero no están disuadiendo a los viajeros
una vez que deciden ir lo hacen solo
buscan otra forma de ajustar el precio
unas previsiones que han llevado a los
expertos a pedir el respeto de las
medidas de bioseguridad durante la
celebración